I don't smoke I am a non smoker thank
you it's pretty obvious why I think
about it smoke it's one of our natural
enemies stings your eyes makes your
breath smell like wet Swamp frog [__] a
lot of smokers in the audience
oh no yeah it kills you that's a nice
little bonus but here's something that
might surprise you I envy smokers I do
I'm not saying you should smoke I'm not
a doctor from the 50s a bee cream for
the hoppin cigarettes for the COFF and
drink a glass of hard liquor every hour
all day until that dandruff clears up no
excuses missed it no not like that I
don't want to smoke and I don't want you
to smoke but being a smoker has a lot of
perks mostly social perks like leaving
loud bars
ooh I love leaving a loud crowded bar
and smokers have a built-in socially
acceptable excuse at any time to step
outside whenever they want just oh great
story great story about how there was no
Jessi and it was all in waltz mine
riveting if you'll excuse me I'm gonna
go outside and kill myself all slow like
me I have to feel awkward if I want to
leave just like The News said no eclipse
tonight but i'ma go outside just to make
sure
that's not cool I want an excuse to go
outside and take a break enjoy the cool
night air like I've been thinking about
I love sandwiches and I really really
wish there was a sandwich that I legally
had to eat outside I'm not kidding
sitting at the bar unwrapping a hoagie
tacking all the ingredients together
lettuce spilling everywhere onions
stinking up the place people giving me
dirty looks like bah you ever heard a
secondhand sandwich pal take it outside
and I would gladly to the parking lot
my respite out there with the one
hipster girl with a pound of loose hot
ham rolling her own
but as long as indoor hoagies are
totally legal I have no reason to go
outside here's another thing I envy
about smokers no fooling
flirting smoking makes it way easier to
flirt sometimes like if you're a smoker
you can say to a stranger that you just
were talking to you for a couple minutes
like hey you want to step outside and
just talk which is me do something
together that we're gonna lie to our
doctors about then you're outside having
a one-on-one in the parking lot like
it's your private patio just like yeah
this is my place the broken glass and
vomit really ties the place together
even the act of smoking itself bond
smokers together it's very intimate
sometimes they're lighting them together
sharing a match getting close sometimes
I'll even hand you the cigarette they're
smoking so you can light yours with it
that's sexual
you're touching tips and sucking just
like
thanks bro
but people flirting and smoking together
are instantly bound to one another for
another reason why now you both smell
like [__] a nonsmoker will never
tolerate that stuff yeah they would
never go home with someone who smells
like they just left a for our debtors
Anonymous meeting think about it that's
why the Marlboro Man was always outside
in that field the wife wouldn't let him
in the house just like oh no you're not
coming in here mister man until you air
out and stop smelling like your finger
Joe Camel